to the break we were talking with Larry
and Larry's going through a divorce
sadly he and his soon-to-be ex maxed out
all his credit cards which he was
supposed to be using for work expenses
and being reimbursed there he could no
longer use them for that because their
maxed out so he can't travel his work
won't help him and they tell him he's
gonna have to take time off without pay
until he fixes his he's got three
hundred dollars in his account to his
name is that a fair summary of what you
told me so far sir yes sir okay what do
you make at this job your leave right at
ninety three thousand bucks what do you
do I'm a field service engineer service
engineer you're an engineer by trade yes
I work on other people industrial
equipment of all sizes and shapes okay
but you have an engineering degree yes
okay well the first thing that comes to
mind is that your time with this company
sounds like it's done that's the first
thing that comes to mind for multiple
reasons
being on the road hasn't worked well for
you paying their expenses for them you
being their bank yeah isn't working well
for you and as an engineer you can
probably make 90 somewhere else you're
out of money you don't have the ability
to borrow to go on the road anymore and
for some odd reason after 15 years
they're unwilling to help you at all
that's either means that they don't like
the level of production that you're
doing or that they're cold hearted or
both how big a company is this a
worldwide company okay that's the
problem
it's
that's the problem is just corporate
America then okay all right no heart no
soul how much debt of you got Larry
total probably around $225,000 setting
house okay how much of that's your home
about 120 okay so you got a hundred
thousand dollars in its consumer debt
yes and how much of that's credit cards
probably round fifteen okay
what's the rest of it three vehicles and
a motorcycle so you got like fifty
thousand dollar cars got 140 and one
that's twenty okay like I said I'm in
the divorce and I cannot sell her
vehicles they I tried to to do that time
to take it out of my name but it's still
in negotiation or arbitration I guess
you might say that they will not I can't
do it until that's final yeah she bought
a new car just just recently in your
name yes how did you sign it
I didn't she fraudulently signed your
name I my names on it and I have to pay
for us that's my that's my dilemma
that's my insurance company I have to
pay the inche car insurance also which
they told me that I could not drop
because it was their company policy
unless I dropped everything that I've
had for over 30 years home okay um
alright so you need to sit down and talk
with your attorney because let me help
the side sidebar for just a second we'll
come back to your media problem you've
got a lot of problems but yeah but if
you're if you did not sign for this car
there's no way on God's green earth in
any state that you should end up liable
for this car if you do you have the
world's worst attorney
well she's committed criminal fraud if
she signs your name
oh okay I can't go and sign your name
and buy a car
even if I'm married to you I can't do
that unless you have a power of attorney
have you given her an unlimited power of
attorney no not recently well ever
I don't remember I've been married 32
years well I've been married 35 years I
know I haven't given my wife an
unlimited power of attorney so I'm
positive of that so anyway the so you
need to sit down with your attorney it
sounds like your soon-to-be ex has
committed criminal fraud that should
enter into the negotiations
you should not end up responsible for a
$40,000 vehicle that you did not sign
for it now that's a sidebar as far as
your insurance company goes tell him to
stick it in their ear okay if they can't
yeah I'm gonna cancel everything in
sight with them they don't get to tell
me what to do I don't who is this who's
this insurance company alpha okay then
go get you another insurance company and
get insurance on your car
why are you insuring her car you know
your attorney sounds like a wuss to me
well he told me just our last meeting
last week that start two weeks ago that
I would he would drop my insurance
company all funny so that's not a law
he said that's their company policy yeah
exactly right I'd go get industry let
her get insurance on a $40,000 car she
signed fraudulently for and don't you
dare pay a payment on that so that's set
aside now we got $15,000 in credit card
debt I'm guessing both of your names are
legitimately on all those credit cards
and I'm guessing both of your names are
legitimately on this $20,000 car what
other debt is there that's basically it
well there is a Lowe's I didn't I just
forgot that that's probably right at
$10,000 bought a piece of property a
couple years ago and that was used to
fix up a couple of trailers on it is
that property do you still own it yes
what's that worth property's actually
probably probably worth $100,000 I found
a light good that's good that's going to
be sold to clean this mess up then so
here's a couple other things
then we're gonna get back to your
original issue the last thing is this in
a divorce you do not want to end you
don't want to end the marriage and stay
on debt with somebody you know and so
this car has to be moved away from you
you need to refinance your car as a part
of the negotiation and get it out of her
name and you be responsible for it and
you probably need to sell it then and
get something cheaper right now as soon
as possible but all of that's going to
be you have to get permission to do all
that that is accurate information from
your attorney so you've got to make sure
you don't stay on the hook to pay
everything if she doesn't pay it because
the one thing we know about her is she's
not reliable now next on what are we
going to do with $300 to your name and
no ability to go to work you're gonna
have to go to work somewhere else and
that may mean delivering pizzas and
driving uber for a tooth for three weeks
to keep your bills paid a little bit
until you get a new engineering job job
doesn't bother me I can get a job
because I would like I say I work in
companies all over the US
I have many contacts with them you know
and offered quite a bit of jobs to come
privately work for them but I didn't
want to lose a good job what I thought
was a good job yeah I don't think you've
got a good job
I don't hate there anymore I don't think
you're working for a good company so
it's you know as soon as you can land
something the better hopefully you can
land it there until you at least get
through this divorce yes because you
need to stay there until you get this
settled and you don't end up holding the
bag on the whole thing because you're
having to fly into Birmingham to new
negotiations
you got groom children or her little
children yeah no my children are grown
there they're gone out of the house
that's financially good news anyway
right it's a lot more things in last
November and early December we had
arbitration dates that I told my company
about and you know the two or three days
before they told me no you cannot leave
that job and go to that which did not
put me in good standings with yeah I won
my lawyer or anybody know exactly does
you you know you do need to look for a
job brother and you got to get something
part-time to eat with until you learn
something hopefully you learn something
a week or two and you may need to move
and if you move that's fine you fly in
for the arbitration and make that part
of your signing deal with the new place
and I'm sorry you're going through this
but break this down into small parts
figure out what's most important and
that last part right now is the most
immediate emergency you've got this is
the Dave Ramsey show